Bud Light to launch camouflage bottle
amid transgender controversy
um you know Bud's now trying to go uh
the other way Miller lied to the weird
thing too I mean Rogan were texting
about it he played it on his show about
how like it was horrible that women
the Miller Lite which was like piss beer
and they're trying to sell it to like
horny dudes who are trying to look at
tits and they're like well women like
can you believe they put women in
bikinis to sell this product like he has
a bad product it's not a great product
yeah it's sex cells is this new
but apparently they did something on
Miller lie I I don't understand what's
going on people that are drinking
American Beer it's like yeah it's
they're selling you garbage they're
gonna sell it with some tits
attached to it that's that's who do you
think's drinking beer well Miller Lite
it's you know Bud Light what do you
think is consuming this aficionados
this isn't for the craft beer heads it's
like [__] guys that are like oh yeah
let's go get [__] similar I just saw
this commercial with a couple of chicks
in bikinis were almost hooking up I I
feel like I'm gonna get Miller now that
Bill Hicks did a whole bit about it
about how much six sex cells where it's
like a model fingering yourself and
she's like buy coke like I mean it's
like
so now they're saying uh they're going
the other way it's an aluminum bottle I
believe it is the only package that will
be transitioning I'm not sure and it's
going to be the company set to launch a
line of camouflage aluminum bottles that
promote the folds of Honor program which
provide educational scholarships for
families have fallen and disabled
American military service members and
First Responders in New York Post
reported
I mean wow
they've gone the other way huh
wow
jeez
so now they're doing
now they're doing like
it's nice you should have done that
anyway to give First Responders things
we didn't you didn't need to have an
uproar
um
I just wonder how Wild it'll got you
know
like how
you know
you know when they start having
commercials like some shade of Hitler
was a bad guy
but we see him as a man that cared about
his country
Bud Light
I mean it's like how
how Wild will it get you know
Nathan Bedford Forrest starting in an
organization called the Knights of the
Church of the Klu Klux Klan
and while that con that organization has
been controversial here in Heartland
we remember when your daddy went out and
he grabbed his hood the only thing he
took with him other than a torch was a
can of Bud Light
Heil Hitler spotlight
Bud Light believes that every American
family has a right to defend their
Homeland from Invaders coming across the
border legally
this is a white country Bud Light
Bud Light believes that European values
Built America you keep your guacamole
and your queso
we'll take God faith family and freedom
bloodline whites only
like how crazy will it get you know
some people think it was six million
but here at Bud Light we haven't seen
the numbers
we're simply saying that history is
never what any one person thinks
Bud Light
find your own number
find the number you're comfortable with
you know bud lights hurt a lot about
diversity being America's strength
but if you look at the shapes of
people's skulls they're different
but like stick with your own
in an exclusive partnership with 4chan
or is this called out eight [__]
well that's what it's called it's not
Bud Light is here to recognize the
Warriors in the battle for free speech
and free expression
that's why
every commemorative can of the Bud Light
will feature the happy Merchant meme
and if you don't like it and [__] off
you're at Bud Light we're a little sick
of hearing about bankers
transnational Bankers that don't give a
[__] about you they just want the
interest on your Goddamn money what
happened to making a living with your
hands instead all this financial mumbo
jumbo
Bud Light watch out for bankers
uh Bud light's getting Flack for its new
cam
which shows
uh the um a militarized border wall
people standing outside
Bud Light believes this country should
be protected
I'll sick dogs on them I'll pouring guns
at their little heads I don't give a
[__]
this is our party
and it's closed Bud Light I mean that
may be the way they have to go
why not
why not just get get a little fun
get a little fun but light believes
Brittany grinder should have been left
in Russia
but I believe play stupid games Win
stupid prizes
Bud Light supports Russia
in its war against the globalist Ukraine
Bud Light
the evil you know
Bud Light sinks there's a lot of Chinese
Communists out there making your kids
trans but you know what we do here at
bud line
we promote traditional wholesome
American values
like questioning why Israel had uh art
students
doing weird surveillance things by the
Twin Towers a few days before anyway
[Music]
Bud Light uh